Sample an individual that it takes your
program and authors his or her future
already has taken the first steps off
response,
personal responsibility by doing
something about it.
So let's assume that we hear we,
we assume responsibility for our lives.
We get our act together and we start
with our rooms and we,
we,
we broadened the circle and we want to
start helping people out in the world
that don't have this first seed of
responsibility.
Um,
and of course some of them also have
diseases they can't do anything about.
We can leave that aside
for now,
but what do we do to inspire others?
Well,
you just laid it out.
I would say it's like,
you know,
one of the things that you,
you pull out of the clinical literature.
Imagine you have children who have a
certain low level amount of neurological
trouble when they're infants.
So something's gone wrong.
Maybe a little oxygen deprivation at
birth or something like that.
Something's going a little bit wrong
with their neurological development.
Assuming that the damage isn't too
severe,
those children will stabilize and
normalize if they have at least one well
put together role model in their life.
And so one of the things that you do if
you want to inspire others is get your
act together because you inspire most
through example.
It's more much more powerful than,
than words.
Words are very powerful if they're also
accompanied by example,
but the best thing you can do is start
putting things together around you.
There's plenty of things to put
together.
It's a good meditative exercise.
You know,
if you're,
and I think this is the proper form of
prayer,
let's say,
assuming that there is such a thing,
I'm proper form of prayer would be if
you're not happy with your life,
if you're miserable,
you sit on the edge of your bed and you
think,
is there anything I can change in what
I'm doing that is going to make this
less awful than it has to be less awful
than it might be?
You have to ask that,
you know,
with intent and generally speaking,
you'll get an answer almost immediately.
There's something that you could put
right that day that would make things
slightly better than they are.
And that's rule four,
which is compare yourself to who you are
yet to who you were yesterday and not to
who someone else's today.
There,
I don't believe that there's a person
who exists who wouldn't receive an
answer to that question if they
genuinely asked it.
And it's no different really than
thinking like if you,
you have a problem,
you think you get an answer might not be
the right answer,
but obviously you get an answer and you
might think,
well,
I thought up that answer.
It's like,
well that's really not much of an
explanation because you don't know how
you think.
It's like I'm sitting there and thoughts
appear in my head and that's how I think
it's like that's a pretty shallow
explanation.
It's not much different than revelation.
It's like you ask yourself the proper
questions,
you'll get the proper answers if you ask
the right question and you want the
answers right.
And those are not easy preconditions to
set up because who knows?
You know,
if you're sitting on the edge of your
bed thinking,
okay,
what am I doing wrong?
That's a hell of a question to ask.
You know,
because if you really want to know,
you'll find out and then you'll find out
that you really didn't want to know.
Because generally speaking,
finding out what you're doing wrong is
not a pleasant experience and it means
that you have to sacrifice part of
yourself,
usually a burned out,
stupid,
bitter,
corrupt,
arrogant,
nasty,
vengeful part of yourself,
but nonetheless part that you like.
And so,
so you can,
I think that room for those incremental
improvements exists within everyone's
grasp.
And,
and I think that it's a humble thing to
do,
to ask how you could improve
incrementally without interfering with
anyone else.
Like it's your problem,
not theirs.
But I think that the consequences of
maintained incremental improvement are
anything but incremental.
You get compound interest on incremental
improvement.
You know,
there's another rule in the New
Testament called the Matthew principle.
It's economists use it and the rule is
to those who have everything more will
be given.
And from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken to an actually
a description of the way the world
works.
Interestingly enough,
you know that if you've ever played
monopoly,
because that's what happens if you play
monopoly.
And there's a reason for that.
That's a deep reason.
But what,
and it's a very harsh rule because it
means as you start to wander off the
path,
let's say,
the probability that you will wonder
further off the path increases
nonlinearly and that's a terrible thing
to know.
As you wonder towards the edge,
the probability that you'll fall off the
cliff increases and that's a statistical
justification for the concept of hell.
But as you improve the probability that
each improvement will produce a further
improvement increases.
And so perhaps the,
the downside is the cataclysmic
catastrophe that you can engage upon if
you reproduce your moral failings.
But the upside is that each improvement
produces an increment in the probability
of the next improvement.
And I've seen that it's a truism among
behavioral psychologists.
I mean,
although they don't generally phrase it
that way.
If you're a behavioral psychologist and
I am a behavioral psychologist,
what you do is you find out what
essentially you help a person establish
their aim and then you break down what
they're trying to do into attainable
units and you negotiate with them.
You say,
well look,
you know,
um,
well I'm not me.
They say I'm not making use of my time
very well.
Spending three hours a day playing video
games.
And you say,
well,
okay,
hypothetically,
how much time would you like to spend
playing video games?
And they say,
well,
I could probably spend an hour a day
without it interfering with the rest of
my life,
which is kind of the issue,
right?
Because if you play video games,
fine,
but maybe three hours means that you're
not doing your homework or something and
that's not a good game.
So you say,
okay,
well I want to play for an hour a day.
It's like,
okay,
well can you shift to an hour a day
right now?
And this is supposed to be an honest
conversation.
And the person says,
no.
I've tried that lots of times.
Every time I try,
I just fail.
And so you don't say,
well,
quit failing.
Go play one hour a day and the problem
will be solved.
That's a stupid strategy.
You say,
okay,
well look,
you think about this and don't agree to
do this unless you think you will do it
because otherwise it's just a waste of
both of our times.
It's like,
do you think that you could track how
much time you've spent playing video
games for one week?
Don't change anything,
just track it and they think,
yeah,
I could probably do that,
but I might miss a couple of days and
you think,
okay fine,
so here's the deal.
Five out of the next seven days,
you just track how much time you spend
playing video games and the person says,
I think I can do that,
because that's what you want them to
say.
You want them to succeed at.
The improvement is not much of an
improvement,
but it's something,
right?
Then they come back and they say,
well,
yeah,
I was playing about four hours a day,
and so you say,
okay,
well fine,
good work man.
You've got to track.
Now we know what,
we know the parameters of your problem.
It's actually a little worse than you
thought,
but at least he had enough sense to
measure it.
We know where you're at.
Okay.
Do you think you could cut that down to
three and a half hours every day and the
person thinks,
no,
I'm pretty weak willed.
I don't think I could manage that.
You say,
well,
how about this?
Do you think that two of the next seven
days you can only play for three hours?
You think you can manage that and you
don't.
You're not cynical about this.
You're not insulting the person,
any of that.
It's like because you don't care,
all you care is that they make some
incremental movement towards their goal
and the person thinks about that.
If they have any sense and they take
their weakness into account and they
think,
I think I could probably do that.
And then they come back the next week
and they say,
I managed to spend three hours a day
playing video games for three days and
the rest were four hours.
And you say,
good work,
man,
you've just got rid of 25%
12 and a half percent of your problem.
You're one eighth of the way to fixing
it in one week.
And you know the person isn't going to
be all that thrilled with themselves
because they don't do the arithmetic
they do.
And they don't do that projection.
They think,
well,
I'm still pretty damn useless.
I'm playing 25 hours worth of video
games a week.
It's nothing to pat myself on the back
for.
It's like,
yes it is.
It's definitely,
it's a market measurable improvement and
it's a move in the right direction,
you know?
And then you say,
okay,
well on the days you succeeded,
how did you manage to succeed?
And is there a way that you could do it
for four days next week?
How about that?
Or or come,
maybe you could even try five days.
You think you could do that?
And then you also tell the person,
look,
the other thing you've got to understand
is you're not going to improve like
this.
You're gonna improve like this.
So some weeks you're going to come back
and say,
Geez,
I backslid completely.
And I like played for four hours a day
for seven days,
but doesn't matter because that doesn't
mean you failed.
It just means that you slid back,
you want to calculate it over a month or
something like that.
And you know,
generally speaking,
a month later the person's down to
something like two hours a day and
you've figured out a ways of filling
their time in with something productive
otherwise,
and they're on their way.
And the general consequence of that is
that every time they manage an
accomplishment,
they get a little stronger in character.
They get a little bit more confident in
their ability to get a little bit less
wracked with self disgust,
they get a little bit more hopeful about
the future and they get more confident
that they can make another change.
And if you're patient and you have to be
patient with yourself that way,
it's like you reward those incremental
improvements and you don't get all
cynical about them and you think,
okay,
just imagine what would happen if you
kept doing that every week for 10 years.
And the answer to that is things would
be so much better for you that you can't
even imagine it with that much
improvement,
or maybe even with half that much
improvement.
And so that's a,
that's a very good way of progressing.
So very good.